so I want to talk about Google keep the
new note taking app they released this
week but first why don't you tell us a
little bit about the device that you're
going to show it off on yeah this here
is the HTC One this is the new flagship
from HTC and it is a fantastic really
really impressive smartphone it's not
out in the US yet this is actually a
Europe and Asia version of the handset
but hopefully we'll be right arriving
the US soon when can i buy it well HTC
hasn't given us a date yet they're
actually they're hoping to get out in
March that may or may not happen
probably not because of supplier delays
they can't get parts because they're not
selling as many phones as Samsung these
other guys oh really yeah so they're
having a hard time fulfilling it's a man
US market it is a massive boner because
it's a great phone yeah but when it does
come out I mean you know it's going to
be one of those things where they put it
out on all the networks since it's a
flagship phone yeah actually this
phone's going to be coming out on
t-mobile AT&T and Sprint there are
rumors that the one will arrive for
verizon HTC hasn't confirmed that yet
but let's hope so cuz that would be a
beautiful thing hold out hope for the
one yeah yeah it is this this is the
successor to the the One X and the one
x+ yes this is like that next big thing
and the one x + 1 x plus were some of
our favorite Android handsets last year
so this one no changes I mean changes of
the film but no changes is how we feel
about HTC's big phones oh yeah I mean
they always come through with quality
it's a shame that more people don't
actually buy them though can we make
really good stuff well here's you know
something else to entice people to you
know buy it yeah which is that it's run
snappy and that Google keep looks really
good on it go everything looks good on
it because their version of Android is
as close to stock Android as damn near
anybody making an android phone it's
fantastic except for the Nexus devices
except which is just talking so tell us
a little bit about keep so keep is an
app that I wish Android would have had
basically since the since the beginning
google has never had a native
note-taking you know checklist app well
they've had tasks they've had task
that sort of love gmail yeah I've had
and it was like really clumsy to get to
in gmail and it was web-based it's a
pain in the butt and it doesn't really
work well on the mobile side right now
if you have an iphone you have notes and
you have reminders and those sync with
your calendar and they work really well
there are a lot of third-party apps a
lot of people use Evernote for things
like this but Android has never had an
answer to that problem built-in baked in
and now finally Google is serving
something up so what you can do here you
can like jot down notes you can create
lists like a grocery list you can record
your own little voice reminders and then
you it'll transcribe it for you and
playback recording of the reminder for
you and you can take photos and then
save them here as like a photographic
reminder and then you can show it to any
social network you want the right you
could publish it to Instagram even if
you want yeah yeah so one of my favorite
things about Evernote was that it was
one of the first apps that I saw where
you could take a picture of like a wine
label yeah and then there's OCR so it'll
read the name of the wine and producer
and everything the mineral you know
it'll make that text searchable so you
search for you know Merlot and it brings
up all the labels the pictures of the
labels yeah you didn't tag him or any
yeah just knows that they saved Milo on
yes so does it have anything like that
big no nothing like that yet there's
nothing like that they have the
capability to do that yeah google
goggles does some of that kind of stuff
I mean they're they have the capability
to do that they also have the capability
to you know integrate this with calendar
which they haven't done yet so okay you
can't have like a timed reminder here
you can't take a note here and add it to
your you know your gmail or your
calendar to set up a time to remind or
anything at that no location-based
reminders either which is something that
iOS offers so there's still a lot of
features here that are lacking so if
you're an Evernote user keeps probably
not going to pull you away but if you've
never gotten into Evernote and you're
living in the Google ecosystem and
that's about it then you're probably
really going to dig this okay I'm still
a bit of a conspiracy theorist about it
where I think maybe they didn't do that
because they didn't want to steal
anybody else's Thunder but it's also
possible they just they need to get
something out I think I think it might
see more dealt yeah I think it might
I mean there's a lot of stuff I'd like
to see I'd love to see that I'd love to
see location-based reminders I'd love to
see integration with you know right now
just really integrates with Google Drive
I'd love to see it like work with
calendar and gmail and all sorts of
stuff so and it is nicely get
notifications of widgets out of it yeah
that is pretty cool there's even a
widget so you can add a reminder a note
from your lockscreen you didn't have to
get into the phone so that's pretty
awesome handy handy yeah all right
Google keep awesome thanks for that no
problem we're going to maricon Robbie to
talk about the kindle
so something new from amazon this week
yeah so they've they pushed out a sin to
kindle button so if you have a wordpress
blog or if you're a major site or with
the developer of course you can add to
send them send the kindle button to your
site so if you have an article usually
long reads you can just click on it and
it'll send it to your kindle house you
log into your amazon account and send it
off most people are who are amazon
customers are usually logged in
persistently yeah the rest are always
looking to buy something on their prime
account like deodorant or whatever so
it's so it's just it automatically just
delivers it whispernet whatever to your
kindle and all you can do laughs yeah so
it'll send it to your IQ your kindle all
your kindle apps now you can use
whispernet but umm it'll charge you for
further data but it but for Wi-Fi it's
free so your kindle is connected to
Wi-Fi it'll just send it to your kindle
you can choose you know if you have like
three Kindles or a kindle and a couple
Kindles in a couple apps you can choose
which ones it sends to in the settings
oh that's cool so you like oh I only
want to go to the kindle app on my
iPhone or I only wanted to go to my
actual physical kindle so this is
something like you know instapaper or
readability where you like I as a user
can install a bookmarklet to save
something this is something that a
publisher can use yes yes yes so it is
it is like you know like Instapaper
pocket where you can you know you can't
they do have actually a an extension for
chrome and firefox for send a kindle and
oh they do yeah but this is I mean it's
right there at the top of the article
next to like Twitter and Facebook and if
you're still using you know stumbleupon
or whatever so it's right in front of
everybody in front of all these eyes so
it's probably bad news for pocket in and
instant paper you know it might be but I
think it's also kind of a different use
case like the people who are into pocket
Instapaper are very much you know like
iphone people or you know android phone
people whereas people who are to the
kindle are all about the kindle like the
real something there on the kid will i
see them on the bus and I'm married one
of them that you know and you know it
we're not married
ah but yeah you know there's people who
just they read everything on the kindle
and if they're reading on their phone it
just feels weird they don't do it yeah I
don't read on my phone at all really
anymore you learned everything to the
kindle or i read it on the computer okay
i think i'm right now i'm probably about
half half yeah i read books on the
kindle and like singles and that's about
it but yeah i'm a huge it's a paper fan
I'm way into it through almost
everything to there and then like read
it on the boss Sir laying in bed or
whatever so what is it is it out now is
something though it is out now it's on
the the washington post time and another
site whose name escapes me okay but you
know anyone who has a wordpress blog you
can add it to it and then they have it
set up so developers for other sites can
put it on there so we can have it on
wire if we want it to its cool and you
style the button or is it styled with a
little amazon there's thursday like you
could change it a little bit they if you
go to the developer blog you can see
where you can change the font and make
the yeah you can style it up a little
okay so let's revisit this in a couple
of months and see how it's doing yeah
and i know they don't release numbers
for everything but we don't need numbers
for anything anyway that's the latest
news from the Amazon front Thank You
Robbie thank you and I will see you next
time